meine lieben freunde wir haben uns hier
heute mal wieder zahlreich versammelt um
eine neue folge trotz zu händel zu
schauen
ich weiß nicht was mich erwarten sollen
letzten folge ist ja eine neue person
mit auf die insel gekommen namens preis
und die meinungen sind getrennt die
mädels denken sich das heißt der preis
der hat ganz viel reis und is nice und
jungs denken sich eher so der scheiß
köthe wieder am start wir schießen
direkt rein ins vergnügen als erster hat
m resort neigt sich eine seiner
legendären bot partys an land gebracht
und 30 quasi käpt'n iglo von los angeles
noch mal ganz kurz zu ihm vor dem
gehörten boot und macht einmal kranke
partys und ich glaube es würde allen die
da auch irgendwie mit dabei sind zeigen
hey james pryce 899 willkommen auf
meiner dachte ich hole euch in der reihe
lifestyle hier auf eure in sorge
ihr seid so nett wahnsinn alle auch noch
mit keyboard hat er dabei
preis
sogar sein keyboarder dabei kommt das
vor
jetzt im moment ist das nur eine list um
jemanden in die kurve zu kriegen
[Musik]
euch aus wenn junge klavierspieler okay
ist es war ja ich kann ja auch
klavierspielen komm ich zeig euch kurz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ihr das wollt laser luca instagram
schreibt mir gern wenn man in einer
stadt voller erstaunlicher und schöner
menschen aufwächst dann braucht man
talent um aufzufallen
ich habe nicht so viele talente
ein song und sie zerfließt wie butter in
meinen händen chloe die lampe bereit
wir sind komplett bereit preis
ich habe gerade auf meine uhr geguckt
und dachte was ist das
vorbei
fragt einfach nicht schreibt eigene
songs wir sind
er werde
woz
jaja zerfließt die lampe hat direkt wie
butter ich werde ihn nicht in den weg
und lassen sich auch von mir auf dass
der blick und und er blickt sagt alles
sieht nach einer meuterei aus käpt'n
auch jetzt fängt die lampe da entweder
wir sind wir wieder ganz nah am kitsch
faktor der ersten folge angekommen
irgendwie war es ja so dass sich die
folge richtig gut entwickelt hat so was
auch die die messe dahinter angeht so
ein bisschen so hey nicht hier so
oberflächlich sondern wirklich er so
innere werte irgendwie sind abgerutscht
sind war leider ließ knie sind so sah
ich dass sie ins wanken kommt
das sieht auch einen regentanz auch
jetzt ja so ungefähr
ich bin auch präsident von amerika aber
nur so ungefähr ist war auf mega krass
ich habe früher mal in der royal albert
hall in london habe ich ein konzert
gespielt auf meinem piano vor 10.000
leuten eher hass war es war der
weihnachtsball von meinem kindergarten
aber es so ungefähr
sein gesang war urkomisch die für ihn am
liebsten auffressen glory
bei chloé ist das wie wenn du
an den bahnhof gehst und du weißt ein
zug fährt um 14 uhr irgendwie jetzt am
juni wird schon juni wo ist diese kroner
zeit ist wichtig wie so ein special bei
mir vorbeigekommen arbeitet stellt euch
vor siebter junior zugeht um 14 uhr und
ihr seid am bahnhof und checkt das war
ja vor zwei jahren das ticket was ich
mir da gekauft habe so krass ist der zug
schon abgefahren
[Musik]
das ist es ist so krotsch
wirklich er hier mit seinem komischen
möchtegern bekämpften ruhe und sie
irgendwie außer belabern lampe sogar ein
klavier passten gut zusammen vor allem
intellektuell klavier gott
ganz schwer
also ich habe einen ziemlich hohen
intelligenzquotienten
a
trotzdem ziemlich schwer sich das hier
anzuschauen ist witzig ich geb ich nur
glory macht backstage auf groupie
pi
der preis der hat ja auch mal damals
aber war er auch mit dabei und er hat er
auch mit michael jacksons herget aber
nur so ungefähr du hast einen unfairen
vorteil
wieso soll ich machen
fritten verstanden du hast und fernen
vorteil warum ich mag fritten und du
siehst genau so fettig aus wie ein
erster klavier gott ich bin der russell
brand
[Musik]
ich bin dein team absolut
a
es ist so komisch sich anzuschauen wie
die da am flirten sind und ich kriege es
nicht mehr hin mit ich könnte mich war
diese flasche von mir überzeugen könnte
ich sie wahrscheinlich ziemlich leicht
auf meinem boot locken aber das geht
hier ja nicht ein perfektes spiel
immer wenn wenn drei spots sagt muss
sich einschränken
und glaub ich nicht okay und ich bin ein
mann kommt werden wir sehen
gut
ich bin gespannt ich will aber jetzt
auch nicht die ganze folge lang mir
deren komisches geführte jahr anschauen
müssen und habe den gea code auf dem
klavier gelernt und du bist anständig
geblieben
[Musik]
was
komm mach einfach alle schminken sich
neuer tag gesagt es ist echt
frustrierend
mein gott habe ich gar nicht drüber
nachgedacht mein lieblingsmärchen ich
habe sogar die kommen auch zusammen und
hört auf bitte immer in den kommentaren
zu spoilern das will keiner sehen
ich habe die fähre schon mal schaut
interessiert ich bin eher für den
nächsten schritt nicht bereit ist muss
den weg gehen wo ich hoffe ihr kriegt
kein wort heraus
ich hoffe ihr kriegt das hin wie schön
ist doch bitte den steinen hier der weg
hier haben sie alle ihre workshops
gemacht
hier wohnen die awo ist dass die ja ich
will da auch hin
ich hatte zwei kurze shirts mit blauen
honda aber es ist nichts passiert
sehr gut hat mir echt schwer aber ich
bin auch stolz auf mich dass ich so
lange ohne auskommen
wirklich gut der könnte echt harry
potter luca stehen das hier gemeinsam
durch männliche freundschaften oder
weibliche freundschaften entstehen
schroff flirtet mit
mit hallo
geht bitte begebt euch nach draußen um
entweder es gab einen regelverstoß den
wir allerdings nicht auf kamera gesehen
haben oder es passiert ein neuer
workshop im nächsten schritt geht es um
kommunikation körpersprache macht 55
prozent davon aus dass
körpersprache macht 55 prozent
der kommunikation aus also mehr
als verbales im heutigen workshop
erfahren die singles wie man sich auch
ganz ohne worte versteht
okay ich bin gespannt auch jetzt haben
sie da world habe ich habe ich gesehen
wie komischen matten aufgebaut ganz
komisch ich würde allerdings sagen meine
lieben freunde dass wir uns diesen
workshop in drei tage in meiner nächsten
werkstoff tortur händel anschauen jeden
dritten tag reagierte darauf aber jetzt
kommen wieder zwei normale videos auf
einem kanal danach wieder zu hören dann
wieder zwei videos nicht ob ist was alle
drei tage bedeutet wenn euch meine
heutige werkstoff titan allerdings
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch oder die wie der damalige freundin
würde mich echt mega freuen wenn wir
50.000 geschaffen würden
ich bin mega krass zeigt mir halt immer
wieder aufs neue jahr wir feiern das
kannst du noch mache gern weiter damit
luca und jetzt befinden uns auch schon
im auto des heutigen videos wenn ihr
mann kann da noch nicht abonniert hat
dann klickt hier oben kostenlos auf dem
smiley drauf und verpasst keine videos
mehr und hier ist ein video verlinkt
dazu eben auf meinem 2 kanal online
gegangen ist da schauen wir uns nämlich
babys vum tour von ford sieben jahren an
auf jeden fall unterhaltsamen geworden
heute nacht um 0 uhr kommt eine neue
podcast folge online auf spotify